ein Tag essen für 1000 €. eigentlich war
dieses Format schon im Regal zugestaubt
und abgeschrieben aber revolut die
Unterstützer des heutigen Videos haben
uns noch mal zum Leben erweckt ich werde
heute für 1.000 € Essen einer von euch
kann 1000 € gewinnen und ich spinne auch
1000 €. es geht also eigentlich um noch
viel mehr Geld aber ja sind teures Video
deshalb danke an revolut wie machen wir
das ganze jetzt aber im letzten Video
sind wir quasi mit 500 € schon an unsere
Grenzen gelangt deshalb muss ich
wirklich wirklich suchen um Restaurants
zu finden und Mittel und Wege zu finden
das überhaupt hinzubekommen weil das ist
so verdammt viel Geld für einen Tag
deshalb mussten wir mit dem Frühstück
direkt die Latte hochhängen und damit
meine ich wirklich ganz ganz hoch los
geht's
[Musik]
schon gesehen ein Beluga Vodka für 7000
Euro
wir müssen ein neues Video für 100.000
Euro für einpacken wir werden uns
wirklich einfach so eine Variation
bestellen ich habe so in meinem Kopf so
300 für Frühstück
ey Leute ich hoffe ihr wisst die absolut
das auch für mich ist ne also ich würde
mir privat das niemals können aber ich
freue mich auf diese wirklich sehr
luxuriösen Variationen die wir jetzt
hier beim Frühstück genießen dürfen wir
müssen aber trotzdem beide essen sonst
kriegen wir es einfach nicht obwohl wir
im wahrscheinlich teuersten Frühstücksei
sind was ich kenne die kaviardegustation
für zwei Personen müssen wir eigentlich
nehmen oder allein diese Limonen Blinis
klingt schon so jenseits meiner
Vorstellung dass man das probieren muss
ein Gericht für zwei Personen das 189 €
kostet liegt jenseits meiner Forschung
also einfach so eine Strategie machen
so viel Geld auszugeben die Bestellung
steht ich zeige euch wenn sie da ist der
große aus der Küche klassisch zum Brunch
wir werden uns wirklich mehrere Gänge
beim Frühstück genießen dürfen und zum
Mittagessen gehen wir einfach nur zu
einem Imbiss ich weiß jetzt vielleicht
fragen die werden später alle geklärt
was Abendessen wird auch was ganz
anderes als Sie vielleicht denken Hammer
Video wird ein Hammer Tag und ich bin
sehr dankbar los geht's
lachsbauch mit Paprikacreme mit dem
Tradition bitte einmal starten das ist
der ausgewogenste unserer Linie wir
unterscheiden bei premier in der Linie
nur im salzungsgrad und der Körnung dann
den St James dass der würzigste unser
Linie und dann den Abschluss mit der
Mann der hat die kleinste Körnung im
früheren russischen Kaviar ist am
intensivsten einfach von Geschmack her
also ganz klassische man eigentlich so
kennt wir haben jetzt die kaviarauswahl
ich habe einen perlmuttlöffel natürlich
bekommen mit dem normalen Silberbesteck
könnte man den Kabel nicht essen weil er
dann oxidiert und dann schmeckt er nicht
mehr so wie soll das hier sind die
Limone Blinis und das hier gemeinsam mit
dem und diesen beiden Sachen bei 125 €,
aber all das wird erst möglich dank des
Partners des heutigen Videos revolut ich
habe es ja schon eingangs erwähnt aber
ihr könnt heute dank meinem Partner
revolut 1000 € gewinnen klingt gut dann
eröffnet über den Link in meiner
Videobeschreibung ein Konto bei revolut
die kriegt 20 € Startguthaben und top
und habe die Gelegenheit 1000 Euro zu
gewinnen aber was ist revolut eigentlich
revolut ist eine Bank eine mobile Bank
und sie hat über 25 Millionen Nutzer
inklusive mir aber was macht sie
besonders ihr könnt mit revolut ganz
entspannt unterwegs mit eurem Handy in
wenigen Minuten euer Bankkonto eröffnet
das Standardkonto ist für euch
gebührenfrei ohne Bedingungen anders als
jetzt vielleicht von anderen Banken
kennt darüber hinaus bietet euch revolut
aber noch viel viel mehr Funktion an z.B
Ausgaben Analyse und limitsetzung ihr
könnt also sehen wie viel ihr euch für
eine einzelne Kategorie z.B
Restaurantbesuche ausgegeben habt und
euch dann einen individuelles Limit
setzen sollte ich vielleicht auch mal
machen falls jemand auf etwas hinspannen
müsst beispielsweise ein Urlaub ein
Autokauf oder etwas anderes dann könnt
ihr in revolut Sparziele festlegen und
dann nicht nur alleine sondern auch
gemeinsam auf ein Ziel hin sparen indem
ihr einen wollt anlegt was mir
persönlich besonders gut gefällt ist
dass man seinen Wechselgeld in den Wald
einzahlen kann quasi wie mit so einem
klassischen Sparschwein und das ganze
automatisch außerdem ist revolut
wirklich ein 1A Reisebegleiter ich habe
schon die ein oder andere Reise für
dieses Jahr geplant die vielleicht auch
mit Content begleitet wird und ich kann
mit revolut Multi währungskonten
eröffnen in den ich zur
echtzeitwechselkursen gebührenfrei
wechseln kann und das in über 30
Währungen was mir persönlich auch
wichtig ist man kann fast überall
gebührenfrei Geld abheben und das im
Inland und im Ausland wenn das also noch
etwas klingt was etwas für euch sein
könnte dann checkt den Link in der
Beschreibung ab nehmt am Gewinnspiel
teil und ich wünsche euch ganz ganz viel
Erfolg vielleicht gewinnt ja die 1000 €
wir testen uns jetzt von links nach
rechts durch das ist erstmal der
Klassiker also ich glaube muss man mögen
ich mag ja ich finde es wirklich sehr
lecker es ist auch ein Geschmack den man
sonst nicht wirklich bekommt das ist so
ein fischiger Geschmack super ölig
einfach was ganz anderes als man kennt
ich probiere den nächsten
salziger ist ja davor gefällt mir fast
noch besser etwas feinere Körnung dass
er da drüben und jetzt noch die feinen
der letzte und sieht wirklich wunderbar
so diese einzelnen kaviareier
wow
schmeckt man so einen krassen
Unterschied also gerade beim letzten
crazy er hat so eine wirklich ein ganz
feine Konsistenz fast so eine leichte
Bitterkeit hinten raus sehr sehr
außergewöhnliches Erlebnis wirklich aber
ich bin froh dass ich dieses Video drehe
weil ich glaube ich würde es mir selbst
nie bestellen einmal hier vorne
einmal das nikoline
im Laufmantel
Leute also man fühlt sich mehr wie im
Sterne Restaurant das ist schon
vollkommen außerhalb des Rahmens was wir
machen und wir starten mit dem Schauen
George Sandwich das ist so bekannt was
durch das Zusammenspiel von suvit
gegartem kavi und Butter Toast schmecken
soll wie so ein Käse Sandwich obwohl
kein Käse drin ist
schon wirklich wenn das wirklich so viel
von so einem Käse sandwichel viel edlere
Art und Weise wir haben nicht nur hier
heraussticht sondern auch Lachs und das
hier ist Lachsfilet
übelst lecker Qualität spricht
Meerrettich sehr dezent sehr lecker
danke schön was richtig gut aus okay das
ist jetzt ein echtes Finale nicht nur
von Dingen her sondern auch so von der
Portionsgröße allein das hier oben drauf
ein warte Ei jetzt ne
sehr frische Würzung sehr sehr lecker
jetzt bin ich gespannt
ich glaube das hat sich
wir werden beide Sachen von dem
Frühstück und haben 300 € ausgegeben 150
Personen komplett Banane für Frühstück
dafür dass das der teuerste Ort in dem
man frühstücken kann das Essen hier geht
klar bei Getränken würde es halt nach
oben gehen dann wollen wir mal bezahlen
sehr sehr erinnerungswürdiger Besucher
und ich finde jetzt dieser Moment zu
stehen nicht mehr da drin zu sein das
fühlt sich so komisch an genau das
werden Leute von euch die auch schon so
besondere Restaurant Erfahrung hatten
können wenn man dann wieder in der
normalen Welt ist dann ist das erstmal
komisch also fühlt sich jetzt gerade an
und das sagt mir das war wirklich was
besonderes gerade auf gar keinen Fall
was für jeden Tag vielleicht für einmal
im Leben wer es liebt auch öfter aber
auf jeden Fall was besonderes jetzt
gehen wir zumindest
ihr kennt vielleicht aus dem Top
foodsports in Düsseldorf wir sind auf
dem Karlsplatz einem der Orte um
wirklich gut zu essen hier in Düsseldorf
und es gibt einen Stand wo man es am
meisten krachen lassen kann ihr erinnert
euch vielleicht die steakschmiede da
waren wir schon mal und da gibt es ihr
könnt euch vielleicht denken vagio und
wie teuer das ist und was da gibt gucken
wir uns jetzt mal an so geht's zu
okay 467
[Musik]
so sieht also eine 200 Euro Steak Platte
aus baguesteak Kobe Steak der Ursprung
vom Radio beef wunderbar gegrillt wie
ich das hier sehe also wirklich eine
wunderschöne rosa Farbe innen drin man
sieht hier wirklich so dieses
intramuskuläre Fett sowas wirklich so
zwischen den fleischpartikeln ist wir
haben die Marmorierung gesehen
unglaublich dazu ein paar einfache
Pommes gibt's einfach nichts besser
kann man machen was man will aber das
ist wirklich was Besonderes haben hier
noch Himbeeressig und ja
anscheinend weil das beides sehr gut
dazu passt fühlt sich gut an zu wissen
dass dieses Fleisch nicht von mir selbst
gegrillt wird sondern von jemand der
sich wirklich damit auskennen als
allerersten
so drei Euro also 200 ich nehme mal hier
schönes Stückchen
jetzt nehme Alter hier hat man so die
Charakteristik von echten Steak also das
ist schon hammer guck mal bitte die
Saftigkeit anderer wow
sehr sehr krass sehr sehr krass ich habe
jetzt ist ein guter Zeitpunkt für euch
um in die Kommentare zu schreiben ob ihr
heute eher hier seht oder wie heute
morgen bei dem Kaviar Frühstück wo alles
mit viel Tamtam viele anrichtet ist hier
zahlt man wirklich einfach nur für das
Produkt weil Probe Fleisch ist einfach
ein sehr gut ist so dass jedes drin das
was man bekommen kann und genauso
schmeckt auch oder so schmeckt auch
wirklich so die die Fleischsäfte das das
schmilzt alles im Mund und es schmeckt
so doppelt so Steak Kick wie das Steak
ist das Steak dass ich gegessen habe
boah super lecker super lecker geworden
[Gelächter]
sollen wir mal mit teriyaki-soße
probieren und mit dem Himbeeressig
unbedingt
[Musik]
also wir sind auf Wolke 10 nicht auf
Wolke 7 bisher wir hatten Spaß wir haben
die Freude geteilt alle fanden sehr
lecker dass das Stichwort für heute
Abend Freude teilen wir trinken Kaffee
machen uns auf dem Weg nach Köln
leisten können heute Abend und ich freue
mich geiler Tag heute ich hoffe dass du
der gerade zuschaut die 1000 € gewinnst
ich würde sie nämlich gönnen Freunde wir
haben über 500 € übrig wie soll ich die
ausgeben na ja am besten nicht alleine
sondern mit Freunden wir sind hier bei
niemand geringerem als Maximilian Lorenz
im Sterne Restaurant ich bin mir sicher
hier kriegen ja was leckeres es gibt ein
Menü für 49 € pro Person 3 Gang das
heißt wir werden perfekt das Budget
ausreizen das Schönste daran ist dass
nicht nur ich was davon ab sondern auch
meine Freundin
[Musik]
an sich sehen lassen ne schön wir haben
ein störter Teil heute morgen gab es
auch schon Stör als Kaviar dazu gibt es
zur geröstete Nüsse eine grüne Gruß
würde ich sagen Cherrytomaten bisschen
Blattsalat auf jeden Fall was Frisches
würde ich jetzt sagen aber probieren wir
mal auch eine üppige Portion ne man
schmeckt auch auf jeden Fall schon die
Klasse hier heraus also auch wenn das
pro Person auf jeden Fall mit das
günstigste was wir heute essen merkt man
dass das kein Standard ist es kein
normales Essen in Anführungszeichen
sondern wirklich schon was neues es war
wirklich sehr sehr lecker sehr frisch
sehr Appetit anregend deshalb jetzt auch
weiter mit dem Hauptgericht
[Musik]
probieren wir das Ganze einmal erstmal
hausgemachte Kroketten das habe ich aber
mikroketten vergessen die selbstgemacht
war
auch diese Pfeffersoße hat direkt so was
so was bekannt ist also meine Mom hat
was gerne mal gekocht den Feuer so ein
richtiger Blattspinat nicht so ein
Rahmspinat also schmeckt nach viel mehr
als man denkt wenn man geil und jetzt
noch einmal das kalbsfile ich liebe ja
eh mein mein Job und die Videos zu
drehen aber so macht es natürlich
besonders viel Spaß damit Freunden
gemeinsam was soll ich Euch erzählen
Leute ich meine ihr kennt alle
Maximilian Lorenz von meinem Kanal ein
großartiger Koch der auch ein
großartiges Team anführt und das Essen
war unfassbar gut es hat auch nicht
schlechter geschmeckt als das Essen das
heute ein Vielfaches davon gekostet hat
was aber wirklich einfach noch mal
besonders schön war war mit so vielen
Freunden und lieben Menschen gemeinsam
an einem Tisch zu sitzen ein letztes
Highlight an einem Tag der eigentlich
nur aus Highlights Bestand einen Kaffee
Eis
probiere ich jetzt noch wow
sehr lecker
ich glaube dieser Einschätzung sehr
lecker für heute den ganzen Tag gehört
es war wirklich alles sehr lecker was
soll man auch erwarten wenn man
unendlich Geld quasi zur Verfügung hat
und nur das Beste vom Besten bestellen
kann was man will 490 da machen wir
bitte 526,99
damit sind wir auf 0 Euro vielen vielen
lieben Dank an Euch fürs zuschauen an
revolut fürs möglich machen ja ich nehme
das nicht als selbstverständlich schaut
gerne mal in der Beschreibung vorbei bei
revolut wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut ciao